les faits on a dit remonte au 10 mai 81
10 34 ces cultures avaient alors été
mises à sac et le corps d'un homme
exhumés depuis plus de six ans l'
enquête est allé d'un pass en fourreau
bondissement rappelle signé michael
darmon et valérie ermite
nous sommes le 10 mai 1990 et ce que
vont découvrir deux femmes dans le
cimetière juif de carpentras va
bouleverser la france entière ils ont
sûreté le cercueil placé le cercueil ils
ont sorti le monde est habillé de son
assaut ils ont exposé sur une tombe
pierre joxe alors ministre de
l'intérieur se rend immédiatement sur
les lieux lui a déjà son idée sur les
coupables annonce donc le racisme
l'antisémitisme
l'intolérance la sphère devient alors
une affaire d'état le 14 mai à paris
toute la classe politique manifeste côte
à côte et dénonce les idées de l'extrême
droite le front national est montré du
doigt
l'enquète s'emballe des centaines
d'arrestations lieu y compris dans les
milieux skin du sud de la france mais
ces auditions ne donneront rien
l'enquêté est au point mort
jusqu'à l'été 1995
geci foulon une jeune carpentrassienne
croit savoir que les profanateurs sont
des jeunes fils de notables de la ville
comment l'avez-vous su par une amie d'un
profanateurs qu'est ce que vous en
raconter les consulter le nouveau
procureur voudrait croire à cette piste
et annonce des mises en examen rapide
les enquêteurs vont faire en sorte de
d'explorer ces nouvelles pistes jusqu'à
ce que nous découvrions la vérité et
nous découvrirons la mériter un
carpentras tout le monde croit connaître
les auteurs de la profanation
tout le monde y compris jean marie le
pen qui demande le 11 novembre dans la
ville
les excuses publiques de la part de
l'ancien gouvernement socialiste
pourtant l'enquêté s'enlise le climat
devient assez détestable
au point que pour la bonne
administration de la justice le tribunal
de carpentras et le juge d'instruction
sylvie motte sont dessaisi du dossier au
profit du tribunal de marseille
aujourd'hui plus de six ans après la
profanation
retour à la case départ la piste
d'extrême droite de mouvements sont
évoqués le parti nationaliste français
et européens
un mouvement néonazi et le groupe skin
charlemagne tous deux réputés pour leur
extrémisme et leur violence